it's like intoxicated I do need to
finish all of these fries before really
how this is a great burden I mean NASA
in wine country in Northern California
it's my first time here I'm a really
really big fan of wine so I'm
particularly excited about this trip I'm
here to meet my friend sandy who's an
executive chef at the Culinary Institute
of America she's gonna show me some of
her favorite spots around town and she
really knows food and wine so should be
good let's go meet her
my first time in Napa we've got a lot to
show you today because we're gonna start
it got home in the California burger
there's neg on top so it's perfect for
breakfast this is how we should start
every day let's do hi my name is Dave
we'll see I'm the general manager here
at God's roadside at the Oxbow public
market here in Napa God's roadside
serves American roadside classics with
the California twist some of the things
that we serve here on our menu that are
quite popular are California burger that
served with a fried egg we toast our bun
on the griddle with a little bit of
butter Charbroil the hamburger patty
served with crispy Zoe's bacon some
Swiss cheese balsamic onions arugula I
loved the runny yolk of the fried egg
when you bite into it
fries throw down some more food potato
fries we have a chili spice blend of
that burger it's one of my favorites wow
this looks really indulgent so many
places you go to the burgers are all
about the toppings and then the patty is
nothing it's really juicy
it's really good beef and it's delicious
absolutely this is really a sign of a
great burger the Messier the better
these are the sweet-potato fries and
their homemade ranch dressing for it
these are one of my favorite things on
the planet so they're salty spicy and
sweet and then the nice creamy Irby
dressing
Wow it's love these are fantastic when I
think of Napa
I think of wine and like really high-end
food and not necessarily like a great
burger
take that we can save some room because
this is the first stop today I still
have a lot of Napa to show you and the
food is amazing every I mean I don't
doubt you I do need to finish all of
these fries before we leave I can't
blame either
we're at the gardens at CIA at copia
let's take a look around to mean this
looks spectacular already so what's your
favorite part of the garden while we're
standing right in front of my favorite
trees it's in this garden and it's the
variegated lemon tree right here see one
with those beautiful stripes can't wait
for it to be ready nature is just like
soulless yeah we're at the Oxbow public
market and we're gonna get some oysters
we were sitting at Hog Island Oyster
Company because they have the best my
name is Jose Romo and I am the chef here
for Hog Island in Napa
been open for 35 years we started off
with selling five different types of
oysters from there we just started
growing selling a lot of oysters through
our hog Shack what's makes us different
from the other places shuck and Y's I
feel like our suckers take that extra
pride in the oyster making sure the
oysters pull so when I pick out an
oyster I kind of want to make sure it
doesn't have that hinge on there see how
the hinge is just right there just
wiggle a knife like I said back and
forth very softly gingerly once it's
stuck on there you just kind of flip it
up like this as I'm scooting along I'm
going to kind of pry it up and then I'm
gonna go for the abductor muscle last
step would be detaching it from the
backside so now it's it's fully detached
some of the best ways of eating it it's
just by itself you're really getting to
you know taste the oyster for what it is
I mean you can add cocktail sauce you
should at least try it by itself first
this is our hogwash cilantro shallot
jalapeno two types of vinegar but if you
want citrus we have it right here for
you for the experience it's gonna be the
halibut crudo so we actually have some
halibut brought to me this morning
isolate it and what's going on it some
avocado a little bit of Fresno chilies
lemon infused oil we got a blueberry
dressing micro cilantro I want people to
walk away with they can come here
anytime with anybody and have a great
time got some oysters and oh right here
we got a halibut crudo okay crudo is
basically just thinly sliced raw fish
kind of like sashimi
hmm I mean the halibut is is so fresh
that it's melting in your mouth right
away those Fresno's and that sea salt
that was given it the crunch and then
everything else just kind of melts in
your mouth okay so now on to the main
event Cheers
it's like intoxicating it's the taste of
laying on the beach yeah when you have
no care in the world what I love about
oysters is where they grow matters but
it's gonna taste completely different
just because of the waters that it's
like wine this is absolutely a must have
in Napa that one's totally different
roll around over you're having a totally
different experience of every single
placement this is a wonderful experience
I can't take all the credit sustainable
seafood at its best we're gonna have to
move on from Hog Island as much as I
would love to stay because we gotta get
you some money
my name is Leo Telus we're here in Sudar
Estate Winery
we're on a 20 acre estate built in 2005
and the first commercial finish was 2003
so we make three wines here at the
winery in production we have our
félicité Cabernet state 1 which is a
Bordeaux blend and a Reserve Cabernet
which is our estate Cabernet Sauvignon
it's a small intimate experience so you
get to see the vineyard walk into the
cave walk into the production side of
the winery so you really get to see
small-scale winemaking in intimate
setting okay so the first wine I'll be
pouring is a 2013 felicity Cabernet 80%
Cabernet been aged 18 to 20 months wow
that's delicious it is delicious the
blend will be basically all the
varieties that we have here that's the
favorite right there it's a beautiful
setting it could be either in Tuscany or
somewhere in Europe but it's located
here in Napa so I'm so excited we're at
Calistoga Ranch we're gonna have dinner
at the lake house restaurant which is
their house restaurant here and it's
gorgeous
my name is Ross Kilkenny executive chef
here at Cal so the ranch we're sitting
here at the lake house which is a
private restaurant at Calistoga Ranch
the lake house focuses on first
seasonality and second is local
sustainable products we utilize farms
within just a hundred miles of the area
what inspires me about the menus
basically is what the farmers are giving
me throughout the weeks we always get
samples of products that are coming out
getting these products in the kitchen
and inspire me to figure out what I'm
gonna do with them today's tasting is a
four-course wine paired meal consisting
of Flav tartare so we use a grass-fed
fillet of beef from Sonoma County
they're using shallots chives capers for
presentation one nice big clean all of
this we make a horseradish cream it's an
aerated compression make the process and
then a slow-cooked egg for the garnish
as well as Australian black truffle
oh wow it is truffle season my god it's
so well-balanced and really subtle a
little bit of spice that comes with that
horseradish oh how beautiful and that
beef and these flavors are just shiny
just spot-on for the second course we
use a seared diver scallops from Maine
that will be served with a corn puree
fresh Peas from the garden blistered
tomatoes from comanche Creek Farms and a
little burden was that a butter sauce
Wow amazing this was like the sea oh the
scallop mathematically it cooked it's
really easy to cook an overdone scallop
this is just beautiful color this is
just such gorgeous color on here and in
my world color equals flavor and it
looks like summer on it it looks like
somewhere I just had a bite of the
tomatoes and I could probably just eat
that under next course is our superior
land a sustainable GMO free product and
that is served with cranberry beans
those are slow-cooked in just a little
mirepoix and bay leaf right now we're
getting really beautiful chanterelles
over with some heirloom toybox carrots
superior land more fresh peas from the
garden and then a little lamb jus Wow
delicious seasoned so perfectly
perfectly you don't know yet [ __ ] Rose
are my favorite moment they're really
earthy and have such a wonderful flavor
and then these cranberry beans these
beans are grown with the greatest of
care you really can't find some of these
heirloom varieties anywhere else right
this is so fun to have this combination
of beans and peas usually I feel like
it's one or the other and for dessert a
peach coffee tea they are cut in half
and then we make the cuff which he
batter and that is her little puffy
shirt a peach ice cream using all the
scraps from the peaches wow this is
beautiful
gorgeous beautiful canal of ice cream
lovely packagers this thing is all about
it and again the peach isn't overly done
so it still has some some bite to it
pansy these edible flowers are really
delicious
great texture so many desserts are
overly yeah you take it just a little
more balanced you - and this is gorgeous
when people come to the lake house the
first thing that they get is a beautiful
view it's a very quiet setting very
romantic as well as a intimate ambiance
I had so many awesome experiences to
choose from a Napa and now I get to
choose how to pay for them with peut
planet from American Express this was
such a big deal of day and I cannot wait
to come back
[Music]